This is really a two-hour presentation I give to high school students,...
...cut down to three minutes.
And it all started one day on a plane, on my way to TED, seven years ago.
So I get off the plane, and I come to TED.
So here we are, seven years, 500 interviews later,...
...and I'm going to tell you what really leads to success and makes TEDsters tick.
And the first thing is passion.
Freeman Thomas says, "I'm driven by my passion."
TEDsters do it for love; they don't do it for money.
Work!
Rupert Murdoch said to me, "It's all hard work.
Nothing comes easily.
But I have a lot of fun."
Good!
Alex Garden says, "To be successful,...
...put your nose down in something and get damn good at it."
There's no magic; it's practice, practice, practice.
And it's focus.
Norman Jewison said to me,...
"I think it all has to do with focusing yourself on one thing."
And push!
David Gallo says, "Push yourself.
Physically, mentally, you've got to push, push, push."
You've got to push through shyness and self-doubt.
Serve!
Sherwin Nuland says, "It was a privilege to serve as a doctor."